i was lucky enough to find my passion
i realized that i was following
something i really cared about
something i loved something i was
passionate about
and i kept following that passion had i
done what my father had wished me to do
which is to go into these
office equipment business with him which
i knew i wasn't
going to do i knew i hated that my life
would have been
unpleasant you know when i went to film
school we said well you're nuts what are
you going to film school for
nobody from a film school had ever
gotten a job in the film business just
had never happened
so you were just doomed to be a ticket
taker disneyland
so they was like why would you do that
you know why don't you take a
major that you can actually get a job at
but once i fell in love with it there
was no going back
even though i had absolutely no chance
of making it in the film business so i
think it's very important not to do
what your peers think you should do
not do what your parents think you
should do or your teachers
or even your culture things but do
what's inside you
you